one of the only things worse than
repealing Obamacare and replacing it
with the American Health Care Act would
be just repealing Obamacare and this is
what Donald Trump and a few Republicans
have been proposing lately and it
appears as though that proposal is dead
but because of some potentially
conflicting comments recently from a
couple of the senators that said that
they were against a straight Obamacare
repeal we're not yet ready to call it
officially dead
so the CBO the Congressional Budget
Office put out a report on what the
impact could be would be of just
repealing Obamacare without any
replacement and it is utterly disastrous
and the one piece from this report that
right-wingers are cheering about is that
if you were to just repeal Obamacare and
not replace it with anything we would
see a decrease in the deficit of 473
billion dollars dot-dot-dot over the
next ten years that's 47 billion dollars
per year this is not even close to
enough to make up for the negative
externalities that would result from it
but okay let's forget about that and
let's say hey you win you say 47 billion
a year which is sort of a drop in the
bucket when you consider the total
budget of the United States what else
would happen if there were to be a
straight Obamacare repeal well number
one 17 million people would end up
without health care just next year a
total of 27 million people would end up
without health care by 2020 and a total
of 32 million people would end up
without health insurance by 2026 roughly
10 percent of the current u.s.
population would end up without health
insurance over the next 10 years if
Obamacare is repealed with an Obamacare
repeal and this is the part that it's
out-of-this-world immoral to even think
about doing this with an Obamacare
repeal you would end up seeing about
half
of the country's population living
somewhere with zero insurers
participating in the non-group market in
other words the market for people who
for whatever reason buy their own
healthcare by 2020 75% of the American
population would be living somewhere by
2026 where they would not have a single
option outside of the group market
meaning through jobs or possibly suits
to some kind of trade organization that
they might be members of so Republicans
like to say will repeal Obamacare people
can still buy insurance just without the
subsidies and they won't be mandated to
buy insurance whatever it'll be fine
it's not true insurers will continue to
pull out of areas to the point that in
ten years if you aren't getting
insurance through work or through
Medicaid or through Medicare if you
still have those available seventy-five
percent of the population would have
zero non-group options to just go and
say I want to buy insurance and this is
completely separate from the 25 percent
that would have options and many would
not be able to afford it because that is
a totally separate issue we're talking
now about even having options and as you
know and as I know and as most of us
understand just because you have an
option doesn't mean that you can afford
it it's like a car dealership that says
we financed everybody nobody will be
turned away but depending on your credit
and your finances and the car you want
to buy they might say sure we've got an
option for you 70 percent down payment
and 30 percent insurance on the rest of
it which will finance for you just
because you have options doesn't mean
that they are real options so this is a
total non-starter for Democrats it
appears as though enough Republicans
realize the disaster that a straight
Obamacare repeal would be so that
they're not going to do it but it's not
a hundred percent known yet and back to
the negative externalities that I talked
about what a lot of people just don't
think about or don't care about or want
to pretend doesn't exist is that if 32
million people end up without health
insurance this is going to impact crime
this is going to impact the number of
unpaid for emergency room visits all of
which has an effect financially on
everybody this will impact worker
productivity this will destroy
entrepreneurial efforts in the United
States if it's going to be that much
more difficult for you to have insurance
if you leave your job and go out on your
own to do something entrepreneurial
you're way more likely to just stick
around in the job you're working at so
that you and potentially your family can
have health care so the deficit
reduction impact does not consider the
negative externalities of 32 million
people ending up without insurance it is
an immoral disaster and like I said
earlier I hope that in the midst of what
is tragic news about John McCain's brain
cancer diagnosis I hope more people will
realize as a result of that what might
happen to millions of people in our
country not only if the Affordable Care
Act is replaced with the American Health
Care Act but if there's just a straight
repeal of the Affordable Care Act it's
to call it sad is a drastic
understatement
today's episode of the David Pakman show
is made possible in part by Warby Parker
eyeglasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right-wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five-day home Tryon from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at-home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription in - I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like in an
eyeglass store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high
even over $300 for prescription glasses
with Warby Parker they started just 95
bucks mine cost that including lenses
and for every pair sold they give a pair
to someone in need so to try the five
pairs and support the David Pakman show
go to Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS